in this lecture sequence we introduced
quite a few new concepts and went
through a fair number of examples so for
this reason it is useful now to just
take stock and summarize the key ideas
and concepts the starting point in a
Bayesian inference problem is the
following there is an unknown parameter
theta and were given a prior
distribution for that parameter we're
also given a model for the observations
X in terms of a distribution that
depends on the unknown parameter theta
the inference problem is as follows we
will be given the value of the random
variable X and then we want to find the
posterior distribution of theta that is
given this particular value of x what is
the conditional distribution of theta in
the case where theta is discrete this
will be in terms of a PMF if theta is
continuous this would be a PDF we find
the posterior distribution by using an
appropriate version of the Bayes rule
and here we have four different
combinations or four choices depending
on which variables are discrete or
continuous this is a complete solution
to a Bayesian inference problem a
posterior distribution but if we want to
come up with a single guess of what
theta is then we use a so-called
estimator what an estimator does is that
it calculates a certain value as a
function of the observed data so G
describes the way that the data are
processed because X is random the
estimator itself will be a random
variable but once we obtain a specific
value of our random variable and we
apply this particular estimator then we
get the realized value of the estimator
so we apply G now to the lower case X
and this gives us an estimate which is
actually a number we have seen two
particular ways of constructing
estimates or estimators one of them is
the maximum a posteriori probability
rule in which we choose
estimate that maximizes the posterior
distribution so in the case where theta
is discrete this finds the value of
theta which is the most likely one given
our observation and similarly in the
continuous case it finds the value of
theta at which the conditional PDF of
theta would be largest another estimator
is the one that we call the LMS or least
mean squares estimator which calculates
the conditional expectation of the
unknown parameter given the observations
that we have obtained finally we may be
interested in evaluating the performance
of a given estimator for hypothesis
testing problems were interested in the
probability of error and we have the
conditional probability of error given
the data that I have just observed and
given that I'm using a specific
estimator what is the probability that I
make a mistake and then there's the
overall evaluation of the estimator how
well does it do on the average before I
know what X is going to be and this is
just the probability that I will be
making an incorrect decision for
estimation problems on the other hand
were interested in the distance between
our estimates from the true value of
theta and this leads us to the following
conditional mean squared error given
that we have already obtained an
observation and we come up with an
estimator in particular the value of the
estimator at this time will be
completely determined by the data that
we obtained but theta the unknown
parameter remains random and there's
going to be a certain squared error we
find the conditional expectation of this
squared error in this particular
situation where we have obtained a
specific value of the random variable
capital X on the other hand if we're
looking at the estimator more generally
how well it does on the average then we
look at the unconditional means
squared error then this gives us an
overall performance evaluation how do we
calculate these performance measures
here we live in a conditional universe
and in a Bayesian estimation problem at
some point we do calculate the posterior
distribution of theta given the
measurements so these calculations
involved here consists of just an
integration or summation using the
conditional distribution for example
here we would integrate this quantity
using the conditional density of theta
given the particular value that we have
obtained if we want to now calculate the
unconditional performance then we will
have to use the total probability or
expectation theorem and in that case we
can average over all the possible values
of X to find the overall error so all of
the calculations involve tools and
equations that we have seen and that we
have used in the past so it is just a
matter of connecting those tools with
the specific new concepts that we have
introduced here